je suis pas une trompeuse
j'aime pas non j'aime pas le principe ça
m'emmerde on s'en va si on s'en est pas
heureux on s'en va
et maintenant j'accueille Emmanuel Béart
est un tricky le site
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on te demande pas d'intervenir
tu t'imagines et en plus tu as la coupe
de cheveux de Bruce Willis
tout à l'heure dans les loges
c'est l'avantage des étrangers
Emmanuel Béart et Patrick vous avez
décidé de couper l'herbe sous le pied de
la presse scandale et de venir ce soir à
la télévision pour annoncer votre
liaison voilà formidable
[Applaudissements]
vous saviez pas Christine non c'est nos
familles qui vont être content de le
prendre
tout le monde va être ravi de la prendre
comme ça ça va être mieux le dire
je crois qu'il y avait un endroit où il
fallait l'annoncer c'est ici
vous êtes rencontrés sur le tournage
d'un voteville qui s'appelle un fil à la
pâte de Georges fedo c'est comme ça que
vous avez fait connaissance un film
réalisé par Michel de ville alors avec
peindre alphabétique attention
accrochez-vous il y a du monde Emmanuel
Béart samberling Dominique Blanc Jacques
Bonnafé Mathieu demi Julie Depardieu
Sarah forestier Stanislas Merah tome
novembre Clément Siboni et Patrick simsi
quel distribution
[Applaudissements]
tu vois comme quoi alors donc c'est une
pièce de fedo avec les portes qui
claquent les amants dans le placard il y
a 228 entrées sorties c'est pour dire
c'est drôle c'est féroce c'est très
obsédé par le sexe et l'argent et tout
ça est très bien filmé par par deux
villes la caméra qui virevolte comme ça
une caméra presque chorégraphique tu
vois je vends le film là
tu fais comme les chiens voilà comme ça
c'est cynique mais c'est gay alors il y
a un truc qui est génial dans ce film
c'est que l'adultère évidemment n'est
pas vécu comme une tragédie parce que
souvent dans le cinéma d'aujourd'hui
quand les gens séparent c'est un drame
terrible et tout et là vécu par le mari
alors que là
même le mari le prend légèrement pense à
très bien c'est vrai c'est parce que des
effets d'eau que les hommes infidèles
c'était inhérents à leur fonction de
Marie voilà c'est quelque chose comme ça
le début du pitch parce que le but j'ai
ultra compliqué l'histoire absolument
compliquée trois premières fois c'est ce
qui fait son charme voilà alors Berling
qui joue le séducteur m Emmanuel qui
joue la diva espèce de demi Mondaine qui
est sa maîtresse mais il doit signer un
contrat de mariage avec Sarah forestier
qui est une jeune fille richement dotée
mais la mère de Sara Forestier Dominique
Blanc voudrais bien se taper burning
enfin voilà quoi donc c'est et vous
alors vous êtes un écrivain on pourrait
dire qu'il essaie de vendre des chansons
à la diva c'est ça une espèce de un
clair de notaire qui se prend pour un
artiste et qui et qui vient vendre c'est
des situations qui sont complètement
dingues avec des personnages qui sont
complètement donc effectivement les ça
ça donne voilà ça ne s'arrête pas moi je
l'ai vu avec ma famille et tout le monde
s'est marié voilà alors Emmanuel vous
auriez pu être une diva comme l'héroïne
du du fil à la pâte une espèce de
demi-mondaine et très jeune très jeune
vous avez découvert l'autre à travers
votre mère
militante du Parti communiste à travers
les réunions de cellules dans son salon
et ça vous a amené à découvrir l'autre à
vous intéresser aux autres et alors ce
que j'ai appris en préparant cette
interview qui est incroyable mais ça
m'étonne pas finalement c'est quand vous
étiez ado vous séchez les cours pour
aller dans les cimetières vous
récupériez les les bouquets de fleurs
les gerbes de fleurs sur les tombes les
plus fleuries et vous les mettiez sur
les tombes des gens qui avaient pas de
fleurs ça magnifique moi
[Applaudissements]
les gens sont morts donc c'est vrai que
c'est un drôle de souvenir parce que je
passais beaucoup de temps dans ce
cimetière donc de Cogolin et je me
disais mais il y a une incroyable
injustice voilà donc pendant que ma mère
s'occupait des vivants elle avait raison
moi je m'occupais des morts et je
rétablissais une sorte de justice dans
les bouquets de fleurs je me disais
voilà je répartissais de façon plus
équitable
en même temps vous louez une cabane vous
aviez mis des matelas des tentures des
bougies et vous louiez la cabane pour
des couples qui voulaient aller se
bécoteraient pas les enfants pour aller
s'embrasser dans la chambre donc nous on
avait fait une cabane parce qu'on avait
beaucoup d'imagination pas de télé et
donc on louait ça de francs pour les
gens qui voulaient se bécoter tranquille
quoi je crois qu'il faisait pas grand
chose parce que et maintenant moderniser
je crois qu'il y a un distributeur de
capotes c'est devenu maintenant une
entreprise
alors ce qui est très drôle c'est qu'à
l'époque en vous quittiez Cogolin donc
votre mère vous alliez chez votre père à
Garches et là il est une espèce
d'immense maison avec une piscine et il
y avait vous dites qu'il y avait des
gens qui étaient tellement célèbres que
vous croyez qu'ils étaient morts et
alors il y avait Pompidou Aragon
Brassens Simone Veil ils sont tous morts
je me souviens d'une grande engueulade
avec mon père qui me disait qu'on allait
voir Aragon et je disais mais il est
mort on apprend à l'école je sais bien
qu'il est mort donc effectivement il me
parlait de tous ces personnages que
j'apprenais à l'école dont j'apprenais
les poésies ou les chansons les et pour
moi tous ces gens étaient voilà et vous
les croisiez là mais en fait c'est dans
le salon de votre mère que vous apprenez
la vie en entendant les les récits des
gens qui qui venaient les gens qui
étaient licenciés les gens qui étaient
les femmes qui étaient battues par leur
mari c'était finalement votre votre
éducation finalement
au bout d'un moment c'est certain que
même si pendant des années j'ai eu envie
palier du Diva ou de j'ai eu envie
terriblement de m'embourgeoiser de fuir
tout ça et de me dire que j'allais
m'occuper de moi et de mes enfants et
tout donc voilà les choses vous
racontent très vite étrangement
l'éducation est une chose qui colle à la
peau et qui vous rattrape et qui fait
que tout d'un coup bah je suis parti
dans dans la même direction mais c'est
bien non
comme ma mère et être chanteuse comme
mon père et maintenant effectivement je
suis ambassadrice de l'UNICEF et je rêve
de chanter donc ils vont vous dire que
voilà c'est c'est vous
occupez du manitaire vous aussi non je
m'occupe d'une
charité qui s'appelle
en France on vient de commencer ça
s'appelle une famille en espoir et c'est
ça pour but de sauver les enfants en
grande détresse qui sont devenus
orphelins à cause de la situation soit
économique soit particulièrement en
Afrique du Sud le problème avec le sida
et de les aider à se tenir en famille et
de ne pas les séparer et aider l'aîné de
la famille très souvent un enfant qui a
10 ou 12 ans à
s'occuper de ces petits frères et soeurs
parce que c'est un vrai vrai problème
terrible on peut si les gens veulent
envoyer de l'argent il y a
une adresse à Paris
la magie du direct
c'est ça la télévision
alors vous dites Emmanuel quand vous
parlez de cette époque comme ça vous
êtes dans le salon de votre mère qui
reçoit tous ces gens malheureux vu qu'il
y a ceux qui viennent simplement
chercher de la nourriture il y a ceux
qui viennent raconter n'importe quoi
c'est que ils viennent manger ou dormir
voilà sur le sofa et donc on se lève le
matin et on dit bonjour tu es qui et
voilà on a quelqu'un chez soi et c'est
régulier c'est sa façon de vivre et vous
dites c'est là que j'ai appris à
regarder mon voisin c'est là que j'ai
découvert l'autre donc et cette phrase
que je trouve formidable de vous quand
on a ouvert les yeux on peut plus jamais
les refermer
difficile c'est vrai oui c'est je pense
que une fois qu'on a commencé mais en
même temps je me dis qu'il y a une chose
qui est bien c'est que quand on a une
vue comme ça globale de la situation on
est une forme de cynisme et de et de
désarroi alors que quand on commence à
mettre un pied dedans on se dit ben je
fais pas grand chose mais je fais
quelque chose donc les choses sont
possibles on peut tous faire quelque
chose et je me rends compte comme dirait
ma grand-mère qui a 101 ans et qui est
une femme incroyable elle elle va dans
la rue et elle dit toujours tu vois j'ai
rencontré un clochard et j'ai commencé
par parler avec lui et quelqu'un m'a
suivi quelqu'un est sorti et quelqu'un
donc comme si effectivement ça
provoquait ça fait boule de neige voilà
on se dit que moi je trouve cette femme
incroyable cette famille alors
un peu ouais tant mieux
donc aujourd'hui c'est l'UNICEF
effectivement dont vous êtes une
ambassadrice et est-ce qu'avec les
hommes vous êtes infirmière
ah non j'aime pas ah bon j'aime les
j'aime la part
délicate ou même les faiblesses même
mais j'aime pas un homme enfant ou un
homme malade enfin je veux dire non
c'est pas pour moi
je vais vous laisser filer merci merci
Emmanuel nous disait qu'elle était pas
très infirmière avec les avec les hommes
est-ce que vous êtes Landru avec les
femmes vous moi chers amis Landry avec
les femmes non non impossible impossible
ça voudrait dire les découpe en morceaux
les faire cuire enfin c'est un boulot
c'est nombreux et travailleur ça c'est
bien passé à Cannes cette semaine le
téléfilm a été bien accueilli non
excellent excellent c'est ce que un
petit jus de pomme bien sûr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec Richard Berry sur scène ouais
la radio
c'est vachement bien c'est à dire que je
l'ai vécu comme un show quoi c'était un
mois c'est pour ça que ça s'appelle
radio Timsit quoi c'est pour mouiller
personne on m'a dit à l'antenne un mois
j'ai dit un mois mais j'ai l'antenne
vraiment et donc on est parti c'est vrai
avec Jean-François l'un Alexandre claire
complices on est ensemble
c'est vrai que c'était le côté public
direct et que et que ça c'est comme si
je faisais un spectacle en plus comme
c'est l'époque où vous tourniez
l'androuille à la barbe le bonnet c'est
infernal
c'était un moment c'était c'était du
show je me planquer sur le bureau de
l'expliquer ce que je faisais
vous avez commencé à acteur ensuite
réalisateur ensuite scénariste ensuite
animateur radio c'est un peu la carrière
d'Orson Wels à l'envers d'une certaine
façon non oui tout à fait je retourne
tout à fait oui une autre question
peut-être il y a plus de questions
maintenant on va faire une interview
votre ville
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ça marche ça marche pour tous les
deux est-ce qu'un après-midi Emmanuel
Emmanuel est-ce qu'un après-midi en
rentrant plus tôt vous avez déjà surpris
votre petite amie au lit avec quelqu'un
d'autre
ça serait il serait mort moi je serai en
prison ça serait
moi je préviens avant de rentrer surtout
plus tôt quoi plus tard je préviens pas
plutôt je préviens Emmanuel est-ce que
vous avez déjà fait sortir en amont ou
une maîtresse par la fenêtre en
catastrophe
réfléchis jusqu'à une baisse que dans
les voitures alors
je suis pas une trompeuse
j'aime pas j'aime pas le principe ça
m'emmerde on s'en va si on s'en est pas
heureux on s'en va mais c'est très je
suis désolé c'est mais voilà j'aime pas
ça
j'ai été fidèle quand j'ai aimé j'ai été
fidèle
et toi c'était déjà arrivé de faire
sortir un amant ou une maîtresse par la
fenêtre
c'est marrant il y a des gens ils ont
des emmerdes parce qu'ils sont confiants
en télé tu peux jamais avoir de la peine
pour eux quoi
il a été se confiant télé et puis c'est
ça
qui est terrible comme moi te rendrai
plus sincère c'est vrai c'est déjà bien
c'est vrai qu'on habillé oui mais c'est
pour ça je regarde bientôt je serai
grisonnant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Emmanuel est-ce que vous êtes déjà écrit
si elle mon mari en entendant la porte
d'entrée s'ouvrir j'ai jamais aimé j'ai
jamais je ne suis jamais mariée
ça voudrait dire que tu te trompes et en
plus tu es chez toi non je n'ai jamais
trompé mon mari
est-ce que tu as déjà dit à ta petite
amie mais non c'est pas ce que tu crois
c'est une copine tu es déjà arrivé ça
parce que c'était la vérité à chaque
fois
ça sent le César quel acteur
est-ce que dans l'intimité vous avez
déjà appelé votre petite amie ou votre
fiancée par un autre prénom que le sien
oui c'est arrivé parce que le début
c'était dans vous voyez ce que je veux
dire
en général je prends tout avec le même
prénom d'accord
c'est bien Ginette ça passe pas
Patrick
est-ce que téléphone vous avez déjà
chauffé la mer en pensant que vous aurez
réussi à la fille
non alors non ce qui m'est arrivé c'est
des fois de déconner en appelant un pote
et de tomber sur son père mais ça
c'était pas une relation amoureuse donc
c'est pas du mais
ce bourré et puis chauffer comme ça
c'est à dire dragouiller la main ou
draguer ou faire une déclaration d'amour
à la mer non surtout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est lui qui rêve d'un baiser
t'inquiète pas le plus angoissé c'est
lui
[Rires]
il faut que ça tombe sur moi ça c'est
quoi
embrasser Thierry Ardisson
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Bruce Willis Emmanuel Béart bonne soirée
Thierry bonne soirée
bonne soirée alors
quelle est la carte c'est quoi vous
devez enlever un vêtement vraiment j'ai
préféré vous embrasser
bon c'est bon non c'est bon d'ailleurs
c'est une nouvelle loi à partir de
maintenant c'est à dire que les gens qui
ne veulent pas faire ce qui a écrit sur
la carte peuvent m'embrasser voilà
est-ce qu'on pourrait donner une carte à
mon ami à mon ami team c'est pas l'abri
de me rouler une belle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
écoute c'est pas un gars pour moi c'est
quoi et Marie Thierry Ardisson doit
continuer l'interview la tête de ses
fiches elle est terminée l'interview
viens me faire un baiser
[Musique]
bonne soirée j'adore ce boulot moi tu as
senti un petit goût de Bruce Willis
[Applaudissements]
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu